[Música]
primer día de toque de queda en el
departamento peruano de puno que ha sido
el epicentro de las más recientes
protestas contra el gobierno de Dina
boluarte 17 manifestantes murieron el
lunes y luego un policía fue quemado
conectamos con lima
tensión en Brasil las autoridades de la
capital Federal despliegan a todas las
fuerzas de seguridad ante la
convocatoria de nuevas protestas esta
tarde Serían las primeras desde que los
seguidores de Jair bolsonaro atacaron
las sedes de las tres ramas del poder en
Brasil
y el jefe del cuerpo de la guardia
Revolucionaria islámica de Irán arremete
contra el medio francés
y salami afirmó que el periódico cometió
un gran error al publicar caricaturas
sobre el líder iraní Ali y agregó que
los musulmanes se vengarán analizamos en
minutos
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
yo soy María Clara calle y comenzamos el
Informativo en Perú porque hoy es el
primero de tres días de toque de queda
nocturno en el departamento de puno en
el sur esto luego de que 17
manifestantes fueran asesinados en la
ciudad de juliaca el lunes luego más de
350 personas retuvieron a dos policías y
quemaron hasta la muerte a uno de ellos
José Luis sonko Quispe así continúa el
malestar social que ha habido en Perú
desde la destitución del expresidente
Pedro castillo y la llegada al poder de
Dina boluarte las protestas dejan al
menos 47 muertos vamos a esta hora a
Lima donde está nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías Francisco Buenas
tardes para usted cómo van las jornadas
de protesta en Perú
Buenas tardes la superintendencia de
transportes reporta 61 puntos de
tránsito obstruidos y doce vías
nacionales afectadas en puno la
situación que hoy empieza con el toque
de queda en la noche y también está de
duelo se ha visto reflejada con la
movilización de los pobladores quienes
han cargado féretros de las 17 personas
que murieron durante la jornada de lucha
de las últimas horas ellos visitaron
algunos puntos de la ciudad y esto ha
sido como una muestra de la situación de
dolor que vive en estos momentos el sur
del Perú Mientras tanto en cusco los
manifestantes se enfrentan a las fuerzas
del orden esta población trata de tomar
por la fuerza el aeropuerto José Velasco
astete Mientras tanto en Arequipa otra
región que es también está en conflicto
algunos pobladores intentan realizar
saqueos mientras que otros tratan de
tomar la Plaza Mayor de esa localidad en
la situación respecto a Lima se
encuentra en tensa calma la capital del
Perú se va a convertir el foco de la
atención porque muchos manifestantes han
anunciado que van a trasladar las
jornadas de protesta a Lima Francisco y
una de las reacciones internacionales
más recientes la de Estados Unidos que
llamó a la moderación y respalda la
investigación de las muertes pero
también la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos inicia una visita que
se sabe de esto
Sí justamente los miembros delegados de
la misión de la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos efectuaron su
primera agenda con la presidenta Dina
boluarte y algunos funcionarios de su
gobierno el organismo le ha recomendado
a las autoridades de este país que se
empleen estándares interamericanos de
necesidad y proporcionalidad del uso de
la fuerza y que también se vele por el
respeto de los Derechos Humanos
justamente la presidenta buluarte ha
prometido todas las facilidades la
visita de la misión culmina El Trece de
enero y posteriormente elevará un
informe ante la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos Gracias Francisco por
su reporte y continuamos con las
noticias porque Los Seguidores del
expresidente brasileño Jair bolsonaro
convocaron a nuevas manifestaciones en
Brasilia para esta tarde ante lo que el
interventor federal de la capital
desplegó todas las fuerzas de seguridad
y es que esta sería la primera protesta
desde el 8 de enero cuando los
simpatizantes de bolsonaro atacaron El
Congreso la Corte Suprema justicia y la
casa presidencial además ocurre horas
después de que bolsonaro publicara un
video en redes sociales negando que Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva fue elegido por el
pueblo luego eliminó la publicación
y el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador está reunido con el Primer
Ministro canadiense Justin trudeo es
para que la reunión bilateral sellen el
memorándum de entendimiento para las dos
instituciones que velan por los derechos
de los indígenas en cada país esto luego
de la Cumbre de los líderes de América
del Norte en la que junto a Joe biden
discutieron la migración y el comercio
de los tres países
y las nuevas caricaturas publicadas por
el medio satírico francés chaclipto
revivieron los reclamos por parte de
Irán el medio hizo una convocatoria
sobre dibujos del líder supremo de la
República islámica el ayatola alica
meney para conmemorar los ocho años de
los atentados en contra de la redacción
en París y ahora decenas de iraníes
protestan frente a la embajada francesa
para hablar del tema nos acompaña desde
Barcelona anahita nacir ella es
politóloga y experta en Irán bienvenida
a France 24 las protestas los que
hablaba no han sido las únicas
reacciones y como lo decíamos antes el
jefe del cuerpo de la guardia
Revolucionaria islámica José insalami
sostuvo que los musulmanes se vengarán
tarde que temprano explícanos por qué la
reacción de Irán Y cómo entender estas
palabras
Buenas tardes gracias por la invitación
tenemos que entender todo esto como una
típica propaganda del régimen iraní
cuando se ve acorralado y encuentra que
no tiene otra salida que por ejemplo
amenazar con a este periodo satírico
Como hizo en su momento contra salman
raspy por lo tanto nos tenemos que lo
tenemos que entender En clave de la gran
utilización de los medios de
comunicación del régimen para desviar un
poco también la atención porque siguen
reprimiendo la gente siguen presionando
las personas que protestan contra el
régimen porque en Irán hay toda una
maquinaria represora que está contra la
población que está pidiendo No ya
pequeños cambios en un cambio total de
régimen y usted habla precisamente de
las manifestaciones que ha habido y los
cambios sin embargo el régimen ha
respondido condenando a la horca a
cuatro personas y también Busca la pena
de muerte para otras 26 esto puede
suprimir la que ha sido la peor
agitación política en los últimos años o
por el contrario la indignación puede
promover todavía más las manifestaciones
seguramente tenemos que evaluar la
represión que está haciendo el régimen
actualmente no está sacando toda su
maquinaria posible a la hora de reprimir
la población porque es una cuestión de
decisión política pero sí que es verdad
que todos los movimientos y las
manifestaciones que están saliendo hoy a
la calle tienen como respuesta la
represión la empresa
en la cárcel Las violaciones la tortura
y la pena de muerte porque al final La
amenaza de pena de muerte es un arma
política para tanto por un lado que las
personas que sigan saliendo a
manifestarse se sientan intimidadas como
para dar una respuesta a la comunidad
internacional Es cierto que ahora hay
más de 20.000 personas
en la cárcel sin garantías legales y de
ellas más de 100 están amenazadas por la
ejecución de forma inminente así que
tenemos que seguir siendo los iranes de
fuera los que estemos dando voz a la
lucha de las mujeres y los hombres
iraníes valientes que salen cada día a
pesar de las amenazas del régimen
Gracias por acompañarnos a vosotros y en
España agricultores valencianos
protestan en frente del ministerio para
la transición ecológica y el reto
demográfico ellos quieren que el
gobierno frene su plan para el trasvase
Tajo segura una de las mayores obras de
ingeniería hidráulica que reduciría el
caudal del agua que llega a ciudades
como alicante y murcia el gobierno
quiere aprobarlo este mes pero la
comunidad alega que sería una reducción
muy rápida de fondo también hay una
disputa política entre el psoe y los
opositores del PP y de vox a cinco meses
de las elecciones autonómicas desde
Madrid nos amplía nuestra corresponsal
Marina Colorado
lo que fue la mayor obra de ingeniería
hidráulica en España que inició
operaciones en 1979 y fue motivo de
celebración por la solidaridad entre
regiones que implicaba se ha convertido
en una de las razones de mayor tensión
nacional desde hace décadas el trasvase
Tajo segura es un sistema de
canalización de unos 260 kilómetros que
lleva agua desde el centro de España en
castilla-la mancha hasta el sureste del
país en las provincias de alicante
murcia y Almería un área conocida como
La huerta de Europa por su actividad
agrícola que representa el 65% de las
hortalizas exportadas por España desde
2015 la cantidad de agua trasvasada ha
ido en aumento mientras que las
condiciones climáticas han ido haciendo
del agua un recurso cada vez más escaso
en toda la Península ibérica de hecho
los embalses en la cabecera de este
trasvase Tajo segura están en sus
niveles más bajos desde 1995 para estas
fechas un panorama que comparten
los embalses del país que están al
38,5% de su capacidad la difícil tarea
que tienen ahora gobernantes técnicos y
ecologistas es encontrar una solución
válida a largo plazo que tenga en cuenta
las necesidades hidrológicas del sureste
agrícola español sin olvidarse de que en
este país la sequía no es algo pasajero
y que por el cambio climático empeorará
en los próximos años
el presidente de la federación francesa
de fútbol de fútbol Noel deja el cargo
tras haberse visto involucrado en
escándalos de acoso sexual y mofarse del
ídolo francés zinedine Zidane sin
embargo en los últimos años le cae
también estuvo en la mira por negar la
homofobia y el racismo en el fútbol
era presidente de la federación francesa
de fútbol desde 2011 pero durante su
tiempo en la cima Noel le trae no ha
sido ajeno a los escándalos
en 2019 grupos ante discriminación
pidieron alegrar que dimitiera después
de que dijera que los partidos ya no
deberían detenerse cuando hubiera cantos
homófobos está pidiendo los árbitros que
no paren más sus partidos es un error
parar un partido quiero que los árbitros
dejen de parar partidos unos meses más
tarde afirmó que el racismo no existe en
el mundo del fútbol
en vísperas del mundial de 2022 este
hombre de 81 años también fue criticado
por su excesivo apoyo a Qatar El golpe
final mofarse de Zidane figura
emblemática del fútbol francés en una
entrevista concedida a la radio francesa
legrae declaró que ni siquiera habría
contestado la llamada sisian se hubiera
puesto en contacto con él a raíz de
estos comentarios el jefe del fútbol
francés recibió una avalancha de
críticas incluida la de la ministra
nacional de deportes
parece como si estuviéramos una
competición es partido tras partido
punto tras punto
creo que ya ha fracasado en su tarea de
representar a la federación francesa de
fútbol
el gobierno puso en marcha una auditoría
de la federación y le grae fue convocado
una audiencia El martes la federación
francesa de fútbol comunicó del
presidente abandonó el cargo el cual
quedará con el vicepresidente philippe
diálogo como interino hasta que se
comunican los resultados de la auditoría
encargada los empleados ambulancias
entran de nuevo a paro en Reino Unido es
un segundo día de protestas para exigir
mejores condiciones laborales así
respaldan la huelga que desde hace meses
inició el servicio nacional de salud sin
embargo el gobierno de Richie sunak se
ha negado a aumentar el salario como lo
exigen y hoy ante el parlamento el
Primer Ministro criticó que por los
paros los pacientes no están siendo
atendidos de urgencia sunat además ha
sido criticado por no usar el sistema
Público de salud sino uno privado
y la policía alemana desalojó a
manifestantes climáticos que se oponían
a la expansión de una mina del inimito
uno de los tipos de Carbón más
contaminantes los planes son demoler la
ciudad de lucerat esta semana para
reemplazarla por la mina los activistas
rechazan que Alemania haya resucitado la
energía de Carbón a pesar de haberse
comprometido a energías más limpias
un enfrentamiento cada vez más
recurrente la policía chocó con
activistas climáticos en el oeste de
Alemania por la expansión de una mina de
licmito un tipo de Carbón Sasha es uno
de los cientos de activistas que ocupan
el pueblo abandonado de lucerrat en un
intento por obstaculizar el proyecto
Si queremos apegarnos al acuerdo
climático de París Entonces tenemos que
actuar Aquí y ahora y tenemos que
demostrar que no podemos depender de la
política porque al final del día depende
de nosotros usar nuestros cuerpos para
evitar que la policía liquida el útero
el plan es que la ciudad sea demolida
para dar paso a la expansión de una mina
que produce 25 millones de toneladas del
ignito cada año el más contaminante de
todos los tipos de Carbón la policía
necesita retirar a los activistas y su
asentamiento para que comiencen los
trabajos de demolición
Este despliegue es un desafío porque
como hemos visto tenemos que prever una
confrontación con manifestantes
violentos
pero informes preocupantes sobre el
futuro del planeta han comenzado a
atraer la simpatía del público por este
tipo de manifestaciones como en Austria
donde los activistas que bloquean el
tráfico recibieron el apoyo de los
científicos
comprendo perfectamente que los jóvenes
estén buscando otros métodos y no
podemos dejarlos solos con eso ellos no
son criminales no son extremistas son
jóvenes preocupados que simplemente
eligen un método que les parece
apropiado
las protestas en Alemania son parte de
las crecientes tensiones por la decisión
de Berlín de reactivar el carbón como
medio para hacer frente a la crisis
energética una práctica que amenaza
directamente sus objetivos climáticos en
un momento en el que Europa registró
temperaturas récord durante 2022
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que se conecten a nuestras redes
sociales y a nuestra página web
volvemos en minutos
[Música]